[Music]
if you looked at in the 1860 in the
United States the major occupations in
the United States were you either a farm
worker and the second most important was
you worked as a maid or a servant or
something in somebody's house by 1900 in
40 years that had changed dramatically
and people were in factories working in
factories their Industrial Workers for
rural rural areas have been depopulated
the cities experienced a huge boom in
growth and that caused all courts a
problem there was the Gilded Age too
much money too many immigrants
anti-immigrant stuff the Democratic
party platform of 1896 says we got to
prohibit popper labor from coming in so
all of that's happening in the same
sorts away too much wealth too much
inequality all the same sorts of issues
were present but by 1950 if you look out
that world today across the industrial
world Europe the United States etc those
people that were in industrial jobs had
good jobs they had reasonable wages they
had unemployment compensation they had
health care they had pensions and then
sort of beginning in the 1970s
automation began to take those jobs away
then of course the supply chain
management people began to look for the
lowest producer those jobs went away and
the equilibrium in the 1950s all across
the world was sort of left parties that
were Pro labor and right parties varying
degrees that were anti labor and it
could be multiple party systems like in
Italy or in France or it could be in
Germany where there's a left party CDU
see our right party rather CDU a Left
Party SDP and the FDP in the middle
balancing amount turning politics one
way or the other or in the United States
it's Democrats the Left Party and the
Republican but it was stable but now
that's not that stability is gone
[Music]
it's hard to find to put a political
party together too stable as they were
in the 50s and that's because as the
jobs League attentions change and it
turns out that the result of that is
that there's political it causes
political instability not just here but
put going to brexit the British leaving
the EU France the rise of the National
Front or even the new part that new new
guy who's come in he's not a traditional
Kent so instead of left-right you're
getting a lot of center periphery stuff
in the voting which which is kind of
what you've got in the United States so
yeah these are unstable times and I
think globalization has has generated
most of the instability and nobody has
yet figured out a political or economic
political or economic solution and just
as in the 1880s 1890's immigration is an
issue that comes to the fore
[Music]
it creates wealth inequality soloing so
I think it's Robert Downey and so
there's something called movies called
the iron man or something my
grandchildren watch that stuff on so he
straps on some stuff and flies around
saves the world right well whatever the
last Iron Man was he made 80 million
dollars and that's cuz 320 million
people around the world actually paid
whatever they paid he got a quarter for
each time that's 80 million bucks so
imagine you're the best carpenter or the
best plumber in Palo Alto California
there's no way you can come anywhere
close to that so when you create world
markets they're bigger winners but
you're losers so inequality comes in
country you got to deal with it but it's
not it's not easy to solve it's not easy
to solve and the final problem with it
all is of course that you can say how
this globalization has been a wonderful
thing it's brought billions of people
out of poverty around the world and it
has 600 million Chinese are less poor
today than they were thirty years ago
but it's hard to run for president
united states based on boy this policy
was great for china but that's that's
not that doesn't win votes so you still
have kind of this global system and
local politics if you look at the world
today what's happening is that we're
always thinking about a political
solution but at the same time that's
happening the world of finance and money
and business is making decisions they're
not waiting til the u.s. and france and
germany and so on get their act together
they are as we speak people making
decisions about where x is going to be
produced where y the movement of capital
is determining things so it may be again
that business moves in these ways and
you either get on board or you don't get
on board
[Music]